il s'agit pas aujourd'hui déposer des
plaintes contre personne dénommée qu'il
ne s'agit pas déposé de plainte contre
l'état au contre le laboratoire
astrazeneca la question est très nature
il s'agit d'avoir un accès au dossier et
d'être acteur de l'anc est de pouvoir
solliciter des investigations
[Musique]
j'ignore si mes dossiers ont une
quelconque valeur représentative mais je
constate que la plupart des personnes
décédées sont des personnes jeunes je
constate et ce que me disent les
médecins avec qui j'ai pu échanger que
le risque de thrombose veineuse
cérébrale est un risque réel est sans
doute moins important chez les personnes
un petit peu plus âgés et dans le cadre
de la balance bénéfice risque
il ya avantage pour les personnes un peu
plus âgée à recevoir un vaccin
éventuellement le vaccin astra délicate
[Musique]
on
des difficultés pour convaincre malgré
tous nos citoyens sur l'astra zeneca ce
qui est une problématique à laquelle là
on doit collectivement réfléchir en
termes de communication et de capacité à
convaincre
[Musique]
quel que soit votre âge vous pouvez
recevoir de la strate et n'est qu'à vous
explique les risques et vous signez une
décharge
ça m'inspire d'abord d'un point de vue
politique une communication désastreuse
parce que envisagé de proposer un
produit avec une décharge
cela démontre qu'on n'a pas confiance
dans le produit d'un point de vue
juridique c'est quelque chose qui me
heurte beaucoup puisque d'un point de
vue juridique pour qu'il y ait un
consentement il faut que compensent pas
éclairé
[Musique]
mon
fondamente maintenant les familles avant
de chercher un responsable
elles veulent comprend qui est arrivé à
leurs proches quand vous perdez 1 en
france 24 ans de façon extrêmement
soudaine vous avez besoin d'éléments de
réponse pour faire votre deuil les
réponses vous sont indispensables et
aujourd'hui on est dans cette phase de
questionnement pour obtenir les réponses
ni plus ni moins
[Musique]